-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're so happy to have you all
with us tonight
and, now, let's get to the news.
President Biden spoke
from the White House yesterday
about the economy
and rising prices
and you could kind of tell
things aren't going great.
[ Laughter ]
Top Democrats have reportedly
been pushing the White House
to have President Biden speak
to the press more often.
And so are top Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki said on Monday
that President Biden intends
to run for reelection in 2024.
Okay, if the next election is
between this guy...
[ Laughter ]
...and this guy...
...we have to stop calling it
"running" for president.
[ Laughter ]
Call it like
carefully shuffling.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Obama
was nominated
for a Grammy yesterday,
and this is crazy --
it was
for Best Latin Jazz Album.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Is there anything
that guy can't do?
Republican Congressman
Jim Jordan revealed,
in a new interview, that he had
the coronavirus over the summer
and refused to say whether he's
received the vaccine.
Well, "refused to say"
is pretty big clue.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody refuses to say
when they do the right thing.
"Did you pull all those children
out of that burning
building, sir?"
[ As Jordan ]
I'd rather not say.
[ Laughter ]
Rescuing children
is a personal decision.
[ Laughter ]
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
tweeted out a picture yesterday
of his vacuum cleaner.
He didn't mean to.
He was just trying
to call his daughter.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the average cost
for a ten-person Thanksgiving
dinner is $53,
not including bail money.
[ Laughter ]
Finally,
The Hershey Company offered
a giant, nine-inch, three-pound
Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
this year
that is meant to serve
as a pie on Thanksgiving.
Perfect for anyone
that wants to show their family
they cared enough to stop
at a 7-Eleven on the way.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!